Speaker 1: Let's go next to Audrey from Georgia.
Audrey, you're on the air.
Speaker 4: Hi, David Iglesias.
We've talked before XOM, but I had an interesting
question four years on yesterday, one to ask.
So I was I studied Chinese in college and
I was talking with my Chinese professor yesterday.
Speaker 1: Now, sorry, I'm sorry to interrupt.
Did you study Mandarin or Cantonese Mandarin?
Speaker 4: Oh, OK, good.
And I came to the conclusion that I think
China is a little bit like kind of I think
we treat them very biased in our media and
especially in our education.
And I wanted to get your take on that.
Do you think that China in many ways is sort
of like demonized in our media?
Like if you look in the news, it's always
something bad about them.
There's never any report.
Some like the good things going on in there,
like scientific research and everything.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I would generally speaking
agree that there is a I mean, listen, China
is an economic adversary.
There is no question about that, but they're
also an economic partner, and that's what
makes this so complex.
On the one hand, we have an economy that for
decades has been based on being able to get
cheap stuff from China.
That's what it is.
If we didn't get cheap stuff from China and
we couldn't quickly get it elsewhere and had
to bring all production domestically, we'd
be buying American, as some people say, but
things would cost dramatically more.
And what I see is in a cemetery in if we want
to recognize China as an economic adversary
and along with Russia up there with the U.S.
as being in a battle to be the major of the
three major superpowers, that's fine.
That's accurate.
I have no problem identifying China in that
way.
But so many of the people who wildly talk
about China virus and intellectual property
theft in this stuff seem to not know or recognize
that our entire way of life, including the
purchasing power that we have, is based on
the fact that we manage.
We get so much of our day of our of our products
from China, and I think it would be great
to have a more balanced perspective on that.
Speaker 4: All right, and I was more talking
about also, like in education, very few people
in the United States seem to know anything
about like the politics or the general like
daily life of what
it's like for people in China.
They just that's
Speaker 1: not super surprising, though, that
it's very common that people people in the
United States also know very little about
the lives of people in Russia or in Japan
or in Denmark.
Now you could say, well, China is more important
to know about for the reasons you're laying
out.
But it's not surprising that U.S. education,
at least in the K through 12 level, is very
useful.
Speaker 4: I mean, like in U.S. education,
we learn all about how the Japanese and British
parliament and everything works.
But there's absolutely no involvement in no
other countries, such as like how Russia's
or how China's politics work.
And I think it's something important that
we need to recognize if we're going to have
those important political discussions all
over the news about, you know, like China
getting rid of term limits or anything.
If you're going to understand that, you have
to have
at least a basic knowledge of
Speaker 1: how it works.
I agree with you.
I agree with you completely, Audrey.
Thank you for the call.
You're welcome.
All right.
There is Audrey.